a Tuesday edition of pro football talk
live from the league meetings in Arizona
rolls along NBC Sports Rio NBCSN hello
again to our friends in the UK enjoying
the program on Sky Sports USA we always
love a good story and our next guest
gave us one hell of a story I have one
request though John Dorsey gee Bob
Browns GM the next time you're gonna
make a big trade do it during normal
working hours not at night because
during normal working hours people
aren't working how dare visiting
websites dare you great news in the
middle of the night nobody notices but
that's a normal working hour for us I
mean free agency those things happen if
you can orchestrate a trade like that
you know those those happens now you
know I think both sides benefited from
this you know anytime you know I always
say that you know you lay out all
different types of scenarios and very
rarely does that 1% pan out in this
situation I think the one you know you
you know usually you throw away a
hundred of those scenarios because they
never pan out but this one it was
Tuesday around 4:30 and there's a couple
guys in room and I got off the phone
with David Guetta Minh and I said guys
there's a chance this may really happen
and so it didn't come to fruition until
after we had some more conversation and
then it came around finalization about
7:00 7:30 we're kind of sunk in that you
know what you just you got yourself a
number one receiver that can help your
second-year quarterback propel and help
propel him in his second season right so
so okay so now did the conversations or
was that even talked about a little bit
when the Zeidler Olivier Vernon contract
or a trade gets done was there anything
brought up then or was it that was kind
of done and then this just came about
and and talks and furthering that along
well I'm more of a compartmentalized
thinking I can't really multitask I
think my wife multitask better than I do
in that regards so what I do is I try to
you know you attack one trade and then
you just said you know what no harm no
foul so Tuesday morning I had called
David back and I said how about this
possibility and then you just you throw
that scenario out that and then we
started having conversations majority of
the day so the prior week there were
rumors coming out of Cleveland that
something would be going on
simply with Odell Beckham jr. at that
time there was nothing happening that
those rumors were just that strictly
rumors nothing was going on no talks
that was rumors I mean the only thing
that we were doing because you know we -
we we listened and read things and
things come across my desk so then again
you plan on different scenarios and of
course we had already planned a couple
different scenarios in case that one
ever did come to fruition and so we were
prepared for it I mean that's kind of
what you're doing that you have to do
that nor line a line of work right all
right so take us into Odell Beckham jr.
now just you know your your evaluation
of them and just all the things you like
for about them to make the move I think
is talent speaks for itself in the field
yeah
very rarely do you get to acquire a man
26 years old that still has extended
years Elana's contract left then you mix
in the passion and then you mix in the
competitiveness and then all of a sudden
one of his best friends is on your team
and all of a sudden his college and
former former pro receiver coaches on
your staff and I'm excited I'm excited
for the direction you know what he
brings for us in the direction we were
headed offensive line yeah how hard was
it to make the first move though because
there's that thinking that the one who
calls first is not operating from a
position of strength were you kind of
hoping that maybe Dave Gettleman would
call you me what causes you to finally
pick up the phone and reach out the
Gettleman and say let's talk about this
possible
no harm no foul why not do it so we did
I think Dave and i's relationship spans
back to 30-some years here now so he
understands you know my makeup I
understand David so when you have
relationships like that it's easy to you
know at very direct conversations and
say okay I mean really what so we just
had very frank very direct conversation
there's no hemmin and hawin and
sometimes you can him and han in these
types of deals and they could drag one
for weeks but when you know you have two
people where two organizations are
talking with each other and each side is
going to be better for the trades why
not attempt to do it how about the whole
I mean Odell Beckham jr. is he's such a
handful oh my gosh you know I mean we're
defenders of them we we constantly talk
about we never hear anything bad at a
lot
in New York the players love them we see
the passion that you mentioned you know
how do you kind of do your due diligence
there and in the process I think you do
your research and I think we know enough
people not only in pro football but in
college football as well to get a vast
understanding what this person is all
about I've said this a lot you can't
have enough passionate competitive guys
on your football team and here's a guy
that shows up loves the game of football
his teammates love them and so to me
that that that speaks volumes when your
teammates begin to rave about you right
because that shows the mark of who this
person really is right did you
specifically speak to Jarvis Landry his
former LSU teammate about Odell Beckham
not doing not I've talked to him
afterwards but I didn't talk to him
before now some will say ok the Steelers
give up Antonio Brown for a third-round
pick in a fifth round pick why so much
more farrotto Beckham junior why I first
don't pick a third-round picking a guy
who was a first-round pick good just so
you know I think it should have been
more you won this one just okay this
Odell was 26 he's 26 years old there's a
big difference you expect I mean he's
right there at the prime of his position
and that's why you're willing because I
just watched him played a game of
football and I know when I were we as an
organization were willing to give up for
a compensation standpoint to acquire a
player of this magnitude did you talk to
the Giants at all last year before they
signed him to the long-term contract at
any point from March until August no I
saw Dave gentlemen here at the owners
meeting about this time last year but we
never talked whatsoever about this when
you have a quarterback like Baker
Mayfield who's passed all the tests at
this point seems like he's got great
personality and charisma does that give
you more confidence in this scenario to
go you know my quarterback can handle
another personality at the receiver
position no I mean you know Baker's got
a prese got strong personality I've said
that he is mature beyond his age where
he sits right now I think he understands
he's very comfortable in his own skin
and what you have to do when you
a quarterback like like that it's our
responsibility to make sure you get
playmakers to let him flourish and
develop his skillset for truly what it
is and let him put that on display right
you mentioned the contract situation
with Odell Beckham jr. he's got five
years left I think it's around 74
million there's already been a report
from NFL Network though that he'd like
to get a restructuring at what point are
you bracing for Odell Beckham jr. is
representative to say hey you know you
didn't have to pay the 21 million
upfront the Giants did we'd like a
sweetener like Antonio Brown yeah I
don't think it's a brace I think right
now there's there's X amount of years of
guarantee still left on that contract
but what I want to do is I want to sit
down face to face and just you know
let's talk about this let's talk about
who you are let's talk about who the
Cleveland Browns are and let's move this
thing forward in the positive direction
that's why I look at okay I mean I'm I'm
your biggest fan right now I just hope
you know this all right and I'm gonna
sit here and call you buddy boy hey
buddy boy hey buddy boy do you know who
they know says do you know the Avengers
do you know this The Avengers movies
right with Iron Man and all that I don't
expect you to not ringing about this is
a like if you could see this he's got a
big chin he's got his chin is a little
bigger than yours so I'm not heads
bigger than ones but but still I was
calling you
Thanos on the day because he must help
me taking over these a good thing it's a
good thing generational guy what were
your notes
okay big hands he has big hands my hand
before and he just goes those are 11
inch hands right there that's what he
was good but this is all respect and
then the Thanos thing that I bring it up
just because he he was aggressive to
overcome the Avengers and you're being
aggressive to overcome the nose you
should and I wish I hadn't he's been
talking about maybe we could find a
superhero that fits him I don't know
there's anything super about me say good
luck yeah I don't know Aquaman cuz you
look like you just came out of the ocean
I don't know the the the Browns now yes
over what over the past year I can't
recall a franchise it has gone from more
overlooked to now the center of
attention prime time games who knows how
many four or five are coming are you
ready for is the team ready for this
spotlight that is going to be shining in
a positive way but there's also gonna be
expectations to live up to its why you
played a game of football I mean there's
challenges every year in the game of
football I think it's better to be in
this position than the position two
years ago I think that's what you want
is you want growth do you want guys to
understand that the organization will do
anything and its power to help you
achieve success and that starts with
leadership and that starts with D and
Jimmy Haslem and and they've supplied
the resources for this now it's our our
job to go out and execute the plan
that's that we say you know what maybe
this can work but it doesn't it doesn't
start it starts in one place it starts
with those guys down in that locker room
and those guys got to set the bar high
and that's gonna be under the direction
of Freddie kitchens and then I have
complete faith in Freddie right well
that's where I wanted to go next anyways
just what was it that you saw and
Freddie this year when he took over as
interim coach that gave you the
confidence to go ahead and make him the
guy well it's what you first off its a
his his resume basically was eight games
and there's no better thing than have a
eight you know eight game resume one
display and what happened is you saw a
group of young men when the offensive
side of the ball come together and
believe
you know what this offense of
philosophically what they were trying to
do on offense but what happens is you
see a group of guys come together on
that side of the ball I'm going you know
what there's something to him because he
is he's consistent day in and day out he
will hold players accountable Hills
he's very trustworthy he's and he and he
buys in and with the players and he'll
sit and listen to the place right when
did you get the Green Bay 1984 okay my
first reaction to the Odell Beckham jr.
trade even though the circumstances are
different oh say Reggie wood I felt like
it was red I feel like it's Reggie White
that was the first thing I said when the
rumor came out the week before right
that if this happens this is Reggie
White to Green Bay this legitimizes
Cleveland it puts the team on path for
an eventual championship did you feel
that at all getting a guy like Oh BJ
does it feel like Reggie White no
actually what I felt after the thing is
I said congratulations guys now it's
time to win the next task at hand
because we're third place in the AFC
North four seven eight and one last year
you know let's go to work here okay and
we have a lot more pieces to fill the
move this thing forward
you know expectations that's okay don't
be scared of expectations you know I
mean there comes a point here where you
know the the men in that locker room you
know sometimes you have to dare to be
great every once in a while like I like
I'd tell them so why not be great why
not take a shot at it and do it the
right way yeah are you able to publicly
vlinn now yeah I do every day but I mean
do they do you like get two bites of a
meal before somebody comes over to you
listen whenever I go out in public which
is not very often it's always with
Katharine Jack and Tricia and we're
having the family meal and you know
people will come up and say hi but you
know I'm I'm used to growing up in a
small town so you always sit and talking
to people so I'm used to people talking
to you now and Cleveland please love but
you know it's a great football town that
it really is you know I've I've embraced
the months you know basically a year and
a half since I've been here and I
understand now
you know you understand the relevance of
the Cleveland Browns because I found
this out in 1920 if we're going to talk
about hundred years of NFL football when
the eleven original clubs you know we're
signed in the NFL five of them were from
Ohio so it shows you the importance of
football in Northeastern Ohio which i
think is really cool no doubt well it's
cool what you're doing and we
congratulate I told them my son Phillip
Phillips is a Browns fan he left the
Giants I'm gonna get pretty sure my
niece is a huge Browns fan and during
the own 16 C's and she came that close
to giving up but she ultimately said I
can't I have to come to training camp
tell her she's my guest to come all
right John hey we love having you and we
look forward to talking to you soon
congratulations again and all the best
moving forward thanks you guys
appreciate it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports